I'll put it this way the New York Times  the lies about the Iraq War and all of  that stuff that the the lies about Iraq  that got us into a war that cost what  how many people died yeah really how  many how many innocent civilians were  killed how much money was wasted how  much damage just around the world  because of this  have we sued the New York Times into  Oblivion to make sure they can never  operate again  no of course not they just say well you  know don't do it again  and we all suffer because of it Alex  Jones says incorrect things about a  bunch of families that I I think he was  it was wrong of him to say and in the  end they're like let's make sure he can  never ever run a company they want to  destroy not just his life they want to  destroy the lives of anyone who worked  for him even a guy who's like a  groundskeeper or security guard that's  insane